president trump wasted no time in going
after harris with his campaign
describing her as biden's political
living will
as ben tracy reports the president
seemed to highlight her role in
criticizing
one of his supreme court picks i thought
she was
the meanest
the the most horrible most disrespectful
of anybody in the
u.s senate president trump says he has
not forgotten
senator harris's questioning of justice
brett kavanaugh
at his supreme court confirmation
hearing i'm referring to a specific
subject
and the specific person i'm referring to
is you despite claiming he wanted biden
to pick harris
president trump says he's surprised
biden actually did
after that heated primary debate she was
probably nastier than
even pocahontas to joe biden
she was very disrespectful to joe biden
and it's hard to pick somebody that's
that disrespectful
just minutes after harris's selection
was announced the trump campaign dropped
this attack ad
debuting what appears to be the latest
in presidential put downs
slo joe and phony kamala but when kamala
harris was running for california
attorney general
then businessman donald trump was a
supporter contributing a total of six
thousand dollars to her campaign coffers
in 2011 and 2013.
on a call with trump campaign officials
last night reporters asked them to
explain
why the president gave her money and is
now trashing her a senior campaign
advisor pointed out that harris is a
black woman
and president trump giving her money is
evidence that he's
not racist anthony ben thank you